Sports has always felt like the polar
opposite of virtual reality
one is physical and tactile
the other is perceptual and intangible
one is mainstream and the other is still
pretty niche
but more and more
they're becoming intertwined I think
it's time for my workout
[Music]
you seem like a natural well all right
that's a little too realistic
athletes fans and people just trying to
get in a good workout are discovering
that the virtual world holds new
possibilities
and companies like meta the corporation
behind Facebook are hoping they can draw
new adopters by getting physical
virtually so we think just generally
speaking there's a huge application for
Sports in the metaverse and in virtual
reality
I think it's truly going to enhance the
way that fans players everyone just
experiences Sports going forward
and for the world's most valuable
leagues and teams can these new digital
ecosystems allow fans to not only
consume but participate in their
favorite pastimes
or will they not even make it out of the
Starting Gate that virtual selfie we saw
of Mark Zuckerberg that's a 10 billion
dollar selfie that's what 10 billion
dollars buys you that's where the
criticism is coming so if you wanted to
think of what is the hardest thing we
could possibly do in the metaverse it's
probably in the area of sports today
[Music]
oh
don't tell me I drowned the ball
[Music]
I'm as bad in here as I am in real life
[Music]
Jason Reuben or at least his Avatar
he's the vice president of metaverse
content at meta the company formerly
known as Facebook
he is a long history in games from
creating Crash Bandicoot to forming the
gaming studio naughty dog
however that experience hasn't
translated to Virtual basketball
somebody in the background is coding
furiously to make sure I don't miss at
this point this basketball hoop is part
of meta's horizon worlds a sort of
digital Meetup space where you can build
your avatar and connect with others in
virtual reality doing everything from
work meetings concerts or casual
conversations near a digital Beach is
this the metaverse are we in that right
now or like what would you say this is
right now on the scale we are in the
metaverse in the same way that if you're
on a web page you're in the internet but
you are not the internet right it's
going to take a while for us to build a
massive metaverse that feels like a
metaverse should be and you'll you'll
never see every corner of it I mean
that's part of the fun of it
now the metaverse is a buzzword we've
heard a lot in the last year the
metaverse the next Frontier of the
internet big Tech big Brands big
Ambitions people and companies are
pouring hundreds of millions of dollars
into the vision of the metaverse that
reportedly is a place where we can all
go and hang out and do business and
pretty much live our lives or at least
our avatars can live their lives if you
go back to the 80s there was a movie
movie called Tron
who's that guy that's Tron he fights for
the user people started to imagine what
would it be like if I was inside of the
arcade or what if I was inside of the
computer like what would happen in that
world what kind of opportunities to get
created
this is Ben Grossman the CEO of magnopus
who worked in the VFX and film industry
for years before starting to work on
Bridging the physical and digital Worlds
the internet right now is like a
newspaper it's words pictures you click
on the words it goes to other things you
click on the pictures they move into
videos
so the internet is connected pages
what we're moving towards now is more
the way the world Works connected spaces
if each of those spaces can exist
between the physical layer that we all
live in and a completely virtual layer
consumers will be able to interact with
content the way that they want to in the
context that they want to and probably
moving towards one universal device that
helps them do it
building out this new form of navigating
our digital and physical lives is
something the largest tech companies in
the world are dedicating vast amounts of
resources towards meta Apple Google
Microsoft continue to make long-term
investments in hardware and software to
bring consumers and companies into
immersive 3D worlds I sound like a
boomer even though I'm not but I'm like
I'll just hang out in the real world for
now yeah I mean I am a boomer and I'm
going to say I just want to hang out in
the real world the term metaverse is
pretty problematic because it originates
in science fiction and it's associated
with a little bit of a dystopian Vision
that not everybody would think is you
know something we should all be aspiring
towards building unfortunately all the
other terms that people have come up
with haven't really taken tractions and
then courtesy of Mark Zuckerberg's
decision to change the name of Facebook
to meta now we have metaverse starting
today our company is now meta now we
have a new North Star to help bring the
metaverse to life
meta has invested billions into this
space including reporting a 10 billion
loss last year on its virtual and
augmented reality arm reality labs
this move to the metaverse started back
in 2014. with then Facebook's
acquisition of VR headset maker Oculus
for two billion dollars
so they were really kind of in a very
vulnerable business position with Google
and apple effectively controlling their
access to most of their customers so
Facebook needed to kind of say well I
need something that's next that we can
control in its entirety they would argue
that that's in order to drive a better
experience or in order to create you
know something that you couldn't have
done while working through the plumbing
of the traditional internet I think
renaming themselves meta is probably an
indication that they are tripling down
on this idea that the metaverse is the
next big idea
companies like Google valve Sony and
Microsoft have all introduced products
to the VR and AR space
even apple is rumored to be developing
its own device
meta has been one of the more visible
companies in the space
aiming to create products and content
not just for gamers but for everyone
however early versions of what the
metaverse inside those headsets look
like have not always been met with
excitement there are larger issues here
outside of Mark Zuckerberg posting a
really weird baby like selfie from the
metaverse and his time on the Rogan
podcast it really goes down to whether
or not people can even figure out what
they want a headset for
if corporations want headsets to be the
next smartphones they're going to have
to make virtual reality more accessible
and fun one way to do that Sports
even simple ones like throwing a
basketball in a hoop
next time I do an interview rule number
one gotta learn how to do the basketball
before right
[Music]
there it is all right now now I can go
home and sleep yeah but like that just
gave us something to do that what like
we're talking right like this is what
you would do with a friend doing
something it doesn't have to be
basketball it could be whatever but this
is very different than sitting on BC
with your hands in your lap talking Matt
is really excited about Sports and
Fitness inside VR inside the metaverse
for a lot of reasons but one of the main
reasons is it tends to be a social
activity and VR and the metaverse are
social activities we're excited in a lot
of aspects of sports we're excited in
people's ability to see professional
sports that they might be stuck at home
alone to see it with other people more
excited about people playing sports
together whether it's Recreations of
Real World Sports and virtual reality or
it's new types of sports that you know
only exist in virtuality only exist in
the metaverse and there's also aspects
like training that are you know starting
to work now where people are training to
become baseball players inside virtual
reality inside the metaverse
all right we're ready
okay watch my bun there right there
drill the goal is to score as many
touchdowns as you can show me and Hawk
up so I might need you to show how many
you got yeah I got the high score okay
all right you got your play call tap the
break button boom now you got that
you're good hit break
okay cool boom and then you gotta find
your guy and throw
it
[Applause]
this is NFL Pro Era a newly released
virtual reality game that puts you in
the helmet of your favorite NFL
quarterback
you can select your team pick your
favorite play and then Jessica QB either
hand the ball off to a running back find
an open receiver or take off running
but with the joystick
oh yeah
get that ball out you gotta get the ball
out
the game's available on a couple
headsets and made by developer status
Pro founded by former NFL wide receiver
Andrew Hawkins and former division one
quarterback Troy Jones
the pair started with developing
training products for pro teams that
used augmented reality so athletes could
practice with both real and virtual
teammates
now they want to bring that experience
to a wider audience
[Applause]
football is such a unique game because
it's something that you can enjoy and
why I can spend time with your family
doing but to get on that field and see
it from the player's perspective and
actually play it I do think you'll gain
a deeper appreciation of what goes into
what you see on TVs on Sundays and
that's something that obviously has two
former players we're passionate about we
kind of had this vision of man this
technology was going to be the future
right and how do we find our space in
that we're both former athletes so we
have a specific way of looking at it and
we felt like there was a way for us to
kind of create an experience that
everybody could participate in from
athletes to coaches to front offices to
fans
and in my demo the immersion Factor was
believable it felt like I was actually
taking a snap at akashur Stadium the
sounds of players running at me made me
pray to hold on to the ball for too long
it wasn't perfect however while fans of
teams might recognize their offensive
line by their numbers their faces aren't
as realistic and occasionally you'll see
some players defy some laws of physics
but even when things went wrong the game
still felt fun you see the guy to the
slot right here number three again he's
gonna break inside in the middle let's
try to hit him okay I'm in the middle
when he breaks
with the left-handed touchdown
[Laughter]
NFL pro era is not the first American
football simulator to be created in a VR
headset there have been arcade-like
games like 2md and MVP football as well
as what is essentially immersive
advertising from Gatorade that features
Peyton Manning before we get you back
out there we need to talk about
hydration but importantly it's the first
to have the official license with the
NFL and it's the first NFL branded video
game of any kind outside of Madden to
debut since 2004. I think the NFL you
know just to be clear they had the most
powerful Sports league in the world and
I think for them it's about making sure
they're going into any partnership with
someone it brings value to their fans
and and into the league and when you sit
even people who work for the NFL in the
50-yard line of the Ravens Stadium or
the eagle Stadium or the giant Stadium
they're like wait I even realize that
I've never been in this position and I
think when that started to circulate
around the league and they started to
see how this could potentially change
their fans experience they immediately
saw the value
traditionally fans of the NFL have been
able to have this experience already
through the Madden video game
a yearly release that sells millions of
copies despite lackluster reviews over
the last five years
Madden from publisher EA has the
advantage of launching on all the major
gaming consoles as well as for PC and
mobile devices
Salesforce status Pro however will be
limited to only owners of virtual
reality headsets
we don't know exactly if you know VR is
ready per se that's not something we can
determine but what we know is we can
bring an experience that your fans have
never had and our goal and our hope is
to be one of the experiences that
continues to contribute to the upward
tick of VR and make it more ubiquitous
369 warm up take
all right outside of the draw of major
sports leagues like the NFL one area
that is bringing a larger and more
diverse group of users to VR has been
Fitness
what's up athlete I'm coach Leanne
welcome to sweat Symphony Shake
everything out at first glance this
might sound like the start of any
instructor-led workout hands up but from
inside a headset it feels more like a
mixture of a Peloton class and guitar
Heroes Supernatural was essentially
created by two people who hated working
out and wanted to find a way to make
working out something that was actually
fun instead of dreadful
this is Leanne pedante she's the head of
Fitness for Supernatural a VR app that
feels more like a fitness studio than a
traditional game you put on this headset
and you're transported to a beautiful
immersive location like the Galapagos
Island or the Great Wall of China and
you're smashing or boxing to targets
that are flying at you to music that you
know and love while being coached by a
coach like me who is guiding you through
the experience and reminding you what an
amazing athlete that you are nailing
that backhand
Supernatural is also structured more
like a fitness studio
you buy a membership for around 20 a
month
and you can choose from a list of
workouts like boxing flow meditate and
stretch and new workouts are added every
day
launching in the spring of 2020 the app
game popularity as many people were
searching for ways to work out while
under lockdown
and notably people who didn't
traditionally visit gyms myself I've
been a supernatural athlete for just
over a year now Fitness presents a lot
of barriers for a lot of people a lot of
people feel left out of Fitness or they
feel unwelcome in gyms and supernatural
has the most diverse community of users
and members that I've ever seen in my
career we have members from their 20s to
their 80s and 90s we have members who
are using this to train for ambitious
Sports and we have members who have
never worked out before in their life
and are doing it for the very first time
what's up athlete welcome growing and
expanding that user base especially to
an older and more gender diverse
audience is incredibly important to
companies hoping to profit in the
metaverse on October 28 2021 Facebook
rebranded as meta the next day it
announced plans to buy Supernatural
Studio within for a reported 400 million
dollars
but in July of 2022 the FTC sued to
block that purchase saying meta is
trying to buy its way into a monopoly
over virtual reality
in a statement meta claimed their
purchase would only benefit the industry
saying attempting to Bar meta for making
Acquisitions at all benefits no one
especially if the goal is to encourage
Innovation and competition
while many studios are hard at work to
find what could be the killer app when
it comes to Virtual Reality the other
question that remains is if this new
spatial internet does materialize how
will companies profit from it
and that leads to the bigger existential
questions around the intimate some say
invasive role big tech companies like
meta and products like Facebook play in
our lives
right now there are a lot of companies
that work under a surveillance
capitalism model it's not the greatest
word but it kind of accurately describes
the fact that the people who were once
consumers are actually the product and
their data gets sold to businesses who
then advertise products to them and
that's the economic engine
this advertising business is massive in
2021 meta brought in 116 billion dollars
in revenue and 57 billion dollars in
profit from online ads
in the past Facebook has drawn
blistering criticism from across the
private sector and government Regulators
without its collection and role in
spreading disinformation and hate speech
and devices that would allow you to
access digital worlds also have the
ability to access more data about you
your location your interests and down
the line potentially even your emotions
so a lot of concern has been put into
can we create a healthy economic model
in a metaverse that isn't requiring
advertising and so the reality is
since the metaverse is really just a
mirror of physical Society by digital
means and the Spectrum in between you
can take any way that you can make money
in the physical world and you can just
do it digitally and some of the biggest
sports leagues in the world are already
testing this Theory starting with maybe
the most obvious selling tickets to
virtual games
[Applause]
the new era of Technology with the
metaverse AR VR is really just the
latest chapter in an effort the MBA has
been making for years which is how to
connect the game with fans and more fans
than can fit in the arena
this is Jen Chun head of Partnerships
for the MBA who have been an early
adopter of VR technology
back in 2015 the league was capturing a
VR Courtside experience at a time when
360 cameras were still held together
with tape
the actual capture technology of the
cameras has improved but I think also
it's the experiences around where you
find those games so for example this
last season in addition to being able to
go into Horizon worlds to actually see a
game in VR you could experience that we
built called NBA Lane which celebrated
our 75th Anniversary so instead of just
being able to watch the game you could
go into the virtual amusement park and
actually yourself participate in Slam
Dunk competitions firing t-shirt cannons
and walking around in VR with your
friend or other NBA fans
this last season the Brooklyn Nets and
the Yes Network released what they
called the netaverse a glimpse at what
is possible in the future of viewing
Sports while far from perfect you could
view the game from any perspective on
the court and just like going to a game
in real life her opponents have a
digital economy believe you will be
inclined to purchase merchandise maybe a
virtual hat or Jersey for your favorite
team that your digital Avatar can wear
the MBA has also experimented in the nft
market with digital trading cards based
on Highlights I think what it really
comes down to is the emotional
attachment that fans have to the games
to particular moments in the games and
so to give fans the opportunity to have
a sense of ownership of certain moments
in the games is is an incredible
connection directly to the fans see what
we got here you are number two it's
unclear whether this emotional
connection to teams or players is enough
to create real digital values in these
spaces while topshot cards gain
popularity early their sales have since
declined drastically
but for the NBA creating these digital
experiences in merchandise are more
testing grounds for how future consumers
May behave
innovation has to have a lean forward
bold testing take that first step
mentality to it to build it they will
come kind of attitude but I think it's
most important for us to continue to
make sure that fans can connect to the
MBA
after all leagues like the NBA or NFL
are slow to change especially when it
comes to how we watch
Sports commands some of the largest
meteorite steals in the world in
changing them even to popular streaming
sites has been a slow process
but for meta they have high Ambitions
for how future fans will engage with
sports
the ideal scenario for me is that Sports
gets to a point where in order to truly
experience the fandom of the league
you're most passionate about or the team
you're most passionate about you have to
do it under Quest
the history of of you know new
technology being rolled out certainly
supports Sports helping Drive audiences
we saw it with Fox becoming a major
Network by going out and acquiring NFL
rights we saw DirecTV go after NFL
rights as well in order to get audiences
to pay for their products football up to
13 NFL games every Sunday if you want
them
I love you
I know sir but we're excited to see with
VR in the future is the ability for this
to become a part of your common Behavior
the best way that you could watch
Express and really engage around a live
sports event but as Bang
s having the metaverse whether that's in
AR or VR experience the be the primary
way we consume Sports from a technical
perspective is still a long way off
Sports is fundamentally one of the few
things left in society that is very
dependent on the power of live
[Applause]
latency the time it takes between I did
something and I received input in the
metaverse is extremely critical and very
difficult in sports it's the difference
between win and loss and in the
metaverse it's one of the hardest things
to achieve we're going to take things up
a level and talk about defense and
footwork fifth in front of your face
the metaverse can feel fun at times but
also frustrating and empty
the idea of watching something inside of
it with friends often still requires a
lot of time and effort and there's
almost always some kind of bugs in the
experience
I think for people who are trying to
tackle Sports specifically in the
metaverse the rewards that are on the
table are pretty significant there's a
lot of money in that in that area and
there's a lot of complexity and the
solutions to those problems are pretty
ubiquitous they apply to so many other
things if you can solve the problems in
sports well then you work backwards from
that you can do you know movies and
television type content you could also
get into education and a million other
things it is an argument to be made that
you find those things that have the
biggest Economic Opportunity you work at
solving those problems and then you use
those solutions to kind of go after the
things that have less treasure at the
end of that hunt so to speak and I think
Sports is one of those sectors
[Music]
foreign